diana one day you'll become all that you dream
of and more and everything will be different
this world is not yet ready for all
that you will do you'll become a legend
there's something happening in the next year
warner brothers pictures is bringing you the
biggest premieres. So this is the suicide squad
in theaters and streaming exclusively on hbo max
the exact same day but the what now
in theaters and streaming on
hbo max beginning december 25th
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is going
to be my new wonder woman 1984 trailer video and
i'll break down what's happening with the 2021
movies that warner brothers is releasing on hbo
max they revealed all of their movies next year
are going to be coming to hbo max it's crazy
everybody freaked out when they announced the
news if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos because of this
big hbo max plan we'll do giveaways for hbo max
subscriptions or if you live outside the united
states and you don't get hbo max it'll just be
for the equivalent price don't worry if you don't
have hbo max in your country they have other ways
they're releasing the movie around the same time
in your country so you won't have to worry about
missing out but you're starting with the big stuff
first number five if you guys didn't know what was
happening this past weekend they released this new
wonder woman 1984 trailer at brazil comic con ccxp
that's usually the biggest comic-con style
convention at the end of the year in december
around the world so typically dc marvel sony
with their spider-man stuff do a big comic-con
panel every year at ccxp this year because of
the virus though marvel and sony just completely
skipped out so there was nothing from the marvel
movies nothing from the sony spider-man movies
but warner brothers did a full-blown six-hour
panel and normally that would be amazing we
just got dc fandom which is basically an entire
weekend of dc movies but what wound up happening
is that the panel that they did at ccxp was
basically them just re-airing a lot of the
same clips and trailers from dc fandom earlier
this year so everybody kind of felt like they
phoned it in metaphorically and literally because
all the panels were conducted via zoom video chat
james gunn did everything he could to try and hype
up the suicide squad movie and i am really excited
to see what he did with that but they didn't
really bring any new footage so it just wasn't
that exciting we did get a little new wonder
woman footage though and this past weekend of
course there was the news that warner brothers
dropped that biggest bomb of bombs on the rest
of the movie industry around the world releasing
all their 2021 movies on hbo max we're all kind
of waiting to see how the other studios react
to that and disney is getting ready for a big
investor meeting december 10th in the next week so
everyone's kind of expecting to see what disney's
reaction to this is going to be but just talking
about the footage real quick number four during
the new trailer footage they start on washington
dc and georgetown where it seems like everything
is super chill you just see the city streets
people walking around they have so much fun with
80s stuff during this movie it's going to be crazy
but while this is happening you get the voice over
from hippolyta talking to a young version of
wonder woman the little girl version in the
flashbacks about her powers and what her future's
going to be like because of who she is and what
she can do just like they did during that first
wonder woman movie part of the story takes place
in the past when she was young but most of the
movie takes place in 1984. the big contest that
they show you in the past is them doing a version
of the classic greek games from ancient history
because remember these are amazons they come from
greek history the greek gods the olympics come
from the greeks so of course the amazons would
celebrate a version of the olympics on themyscira
all that stuff is meant to provide some context
for the overall message of the movie like the
moral of the movie and remind wonder woman herself
in present day what her responsibility is to the
world when things go completely off the rails
because she does get swept up in the moment and
succumbs to temptation like everyone else because
of what maxwell lord and cheetah are doing during
the movie that's where all the steve trevor stuff
starts happening in present day i know everybody's
still kind of wondering what the context is for
him and how he comes back and whether or not he's
real or he's fake and she's just imagining it
he's very real and it's all about this special
black rock that was created by a god to grant
people wishes only it works in a very twisted
way if you're a big anime fan think about it like
a full metal alchemist situation the law of equal
exchange you have to give something in order to
get something then to highlight this while that
voiceover is still happening you see her dancing
with steve trevor at the washington monument
the return to steve trevor then things start to
get crazy you see people in london on the other
side of the planet going crazy in the streets
everyone searched to riot this is from much
later in the movie so they kind of jump around
in the timeline of the film through the trailer
then there's a more complete version of the scene
with her in present-day lassoing a jet and using
it to fly through the air just think of it as
quick travel and then you see her use that to
glide through the air in the clouds eventually
you see her floating in the clouds without any
assistance and she pauses for just a hot second
while she full-on lassos a lightning bolt i think
if you consider that the lasso of truth is so
powerful it's created by the gods and there's a
lot of this celestial god level magic in play it's
a little easier to make that leap in logic like oh
okay she's the daughter of zeus one of zeus's
trademark abilities is throwing lightning bolts
she should also have some affinity for lightning
as well they got into that a little bit during
that final battle in the first wonder woman movie
with aries where she starts throwing lightning at
him like she can actually channel lightning the
way that zeus would channel lightning i think they
draw the line at the idea that she can't generate
lightning the way that zeus can generate lightning
we actually see a little bit of that during
the justice league snyder cut trailer with
the version of zeus from the big flashback dark
side war actually just throwing lightning bolts
at darkseid one of the other really cool
things during the wonder woman panel though
is actually pedro pascal talking about his maxwell
lord villain character pedro pascal said that they
were playing up the 80s vibe during the movie so
much that he actually tried to take his villain
performance to nicholas cage territory he didn't
list any specific nicholas cage impression that
he was trying to do during the movie but just
think about the way nicolas cage goes full 100
cage in some of his scenes like this ghostwriter
scene just completely over the top so after doing
all these star wars mandalorian season two videos
with him being all subdued wearing the helmet all
the time it'll be fun to see him go completely
in the other direction with his performances in
wonder woman 1984 but number two of course the
bigger news of this past week is warner brothers
deciding to release all of its 2021 movies on
hbo max next year everybody flipped out not just
regular people like you and me but also the people
that own the movie studios all the theater owners
what's actually happening though is that when
each of the movies are released throughout
the year they're dropping on hbo max and in
movie theaters where movie theaters are open
on the same day the movies will only be available
on hbo max for about a month after they're
released and then they'll take them off and send
them to regular vod like itunes where you have to
pay full price to watch them then a couple months
after that they'll probably come back to hbo max
for longer but all the while allowing theaters to
show them and earn ticket sales if you're already
paying for hbo max you don't have to pay extra
to get all these movies essentially they're free
but you're already paying the price for the
subscription of hbo max so technically they're not
free but you don't have to pay extra it's not like
disney releasing mulan and charging you extra on
top of the disney plus fee this is a one sheet of
all the movies that are coming next year they were
highlighting the only thing you'll see that isn't
on here is the justice league snyder cut because
these movies that are on here were originally
supposed to be theatrical releases in the
justice league snyder cut was always going to
be hbo max wonder woman 1984 is obviously the
big one that's dropping christmas day december
25th of course i'll do videos for that there's
the new mortal kombat movie justice league snyder
cut tom and jerry godzilla vs kong space jam the
suicide squad movie the new doom movie in matrix
4 at the end of the year so number one of course
everyone's now asking what's this going to do to
disney and all the marvel movies and really all
of disney's movies in general because they're
like the other big studio sony still has a lot
of big spider-man stuff but they're not quite as
big as disney will they also try to release their
movies on disney plus doing something similar
so right now black widow is actually the first
marvel movie of 2021 and it's not coming out till
may what's probably going to happen with that is
that things will be less terrible in the world by
that time so the theater situation won't be as bad
but it still won't be back to 100 until the end
of 2021 so what disney's probably going to do is
they'll still release all their movies in theaters
like they planned but within like a week or two of
them releasing them in theaters they'll send the
movie straight to vod so they won't wait that long
before releasing stuff on vod but right now i'm in
the middle of making star wars mandalorian season
2 episodes after the finale in a couple weeks
and after wonder woman 1984 drops the avengers
1 division episodes will start and i will be
doing weekly videos for that marvel has a ton of
stuff coming to disney plus in 2021 between all
the marvel disney plus series like the avengers
end game spin-offs spider-man 3 is still coming
out december 2021 as of me making this video so
that movie's probably going to be fine things
will probably be mostly back to normal by then
i know there's a lot of live-action spider-verse
questions because of something that happened the
past couple of days i do have a separate video
planned about that just for spider-man stuff
but everybody let me know in the comments
what do you think about this hbo max
movies plan for 2021 but i'll try to post that
spider-man 3 spider-verse video later tonight
while you wait for everything click here for
my brand new mandalorian season 2 episode 6
video and click here for that brand new justice
league snyder cut trailer that they just released
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!